es muy difícil de decir si va a haber un
cambio o no Porque también aquí yo creo
que hay que segmentar muy bien los
resultados y ahorita de acuerdo por
ejemplo a los resultados de los Fuentes
nacionales de Turquía ya podemos
nosotros visualizar como el el mapa de
Turquía y qué regiones que su regiones y
que ciudades tienen tendencias de de
votar para arduan y tienen tendencias de
votar para ggp porque a final de cuenta
también son ideologías este María Clara
entonces claramente hay hay una
tradición como bien bien bien
establecido en Turquía también entonces
como siempre ahorita la tendencia es de
que Estambul o las ciudades por ejemplo
como
Crick larelly las ciudades de la región
mediterránea como aiden mula antalia
tienden tienden a votar Este porque
Michael o dado que pues también que mal
que usted lo ha sido por muchos años el
líder de el jefe que lo cual es un es un
partido bastante diferente a comparación
de que representa diferentes valores
quemalistas que representa como un
progresismo más occidental en en muchos
sentidos y diferentes políticos Pues
tienden a votar por él pero también aquí
vemos en el mapa la mayoría de Turquía y
particularmente pues las regiones de
cara Denis o las regiones de ichanado
Siguen votando por arduan
independientemente que todo todos los
retos económicos políticos y de
seguridad que Turquía ha enfrentado
entonces pues es difícil decir María
clara que simplemente este va a ganar el
opositor y va a haber un cambio tan
drástico claramente deseamos que lo
mejor pase para Turquía y pues que
pueblo Turco lo decida de una manera
democrática pero aquí hay que conocer
muy bien el pueblo Turco y sus
tendencias ideológicos también y
claramente todos esos costumbres que que
aparte ha llevado por muchos años porque
ahorita el cambio pues claramente va a
ser drástico particularmente en la
política exterior turca también y más
cuando estamos viviendo unos tiempos
complejos tal como el contexto de la
guerra ruso ucraniana las políticas de
la otan que va a pasar con la relación
con Estados Unidos etcétera